hello
my name is sajnar simmon i'm a product
manager uh
in google cloud for cloud ai notebooks
today i'm going to walk you through an
overview of cloud ai notebooks
our managed jupyter lab notebook service
for enterprises on google cloud
today we'll explore how cloud ai
notebooks can help you explore data
quickly
and develop an ai and ml model and
deploy it into production
artificial intelligence and machine
learning is
are one of the most are one of the key
disruptive technologies that
enterprises have encountered in the last
four or five years
and ai and ml will continue to disrupt
enterprises
going forward for the next 10 years
the key to unlocking value with
artificial intelligence starts with a
model
and the simplest way to develop a model
is to use notebooks
and within notebooks to use open source
frameworks to develop
uh ai models uh tensorflow pi torch and
many other
oss distributions exist today
that can help you quickly develop a
model and gain insights
as a data point today more than 8
million
jupiter notebooks run on github and this
node
this notebook account only is going to
continue
to grow google has been in the forefront
of
bringing notebooks to different segments
of customers
over the past decade kaggle for example
is targeted at enthusiasts and people
who are learning to be data scientists
colab is targeted at individual
researchers and students
and it provides a collaborative
environment for
developing data science algorithms ai
platform notebooks are targeted towards
enterprises
this means that air perform notebooks
come with
security built in which enterprises
really care about
today we're going to spend some time
looking at ai platforms
and how it can speed up your model
development
so as we noted enterprises want insights
in days
not weeks this means that data
scientists want to focus
on the difficult job of model
development and not essentially the
peripheral task that goes around
running a notebook and the
infrastructure associated with a
notebook
enterprises encounter several challenges
in running notebooks and open source
frameworks
the first thing is around managing open
source frameworks and making these
making the operating systems the
frameworks the dependencies work
correctly
hosting notebooks and maintaining them
on top of these frameworks is an
additional pain point
customers also want to make sure that
the access to the data that data
scientists use
and the models developed from the
notebook themselves are secure
and they're only accessible by the right
personnel
since ai and ml involves accessing data
across the enterprise landscape
it is important for a notebook service
to connect with all of the data sources
that reside within uh an enterprises
data estate
our ai platform notebook service solves
these problems by providing three key
features
we completely manage the installation of
the jupyter notebook environment
along with all the open source
frameworks and dependencies so you don't
have to manage
any of that lifecycle our notebooks also
ship with uh security features like
vpcse
uh cmac and other gcp horizontal
features built-in
and clari notebooks is also integrated
with several
data services like bigquery and dataproc
that we'll dive into a little later uh
notebooks are really easy to get started
all you have to do is to go to the gcp
console
um find notebooks under the ai platform
notebook
create a new instance with the required
deep learning framework and the type of
vm that you want to run the notebook on
so what makes cloud ai notebooks a fully
managed experience
what we do as part of claudii notebooks
is to pre-install
all the client libraries in all the
environments we support popular
open source environments like tensorflow
pytorch
and mathematical libraries like numpy
and scipy
to plot we also provide open source
tools like matplotlib
built right into our deep learning vm
on top of these deep learning vms our
notebooks run and they take advantage
of these deep learning libraries
customers can configure
the notebooks to the cloud console
however they can also get a link to
access the jupyter notebook
using a proxy outside of the gcp console
clari notebooks are designed to work
with different kinds of
compute instances within gcp um cloud ai
notebooks can run with dlvms as we just
spoke about these are gce instances that
come pre-installed with
deep learning frameworks claudia
notebooks can also work with dataproc
clusters
and dataflow ai claudia platforms also
work with custom containers so if you
had a specific deep learning library
that you want to run within the custom
container you can do so
and install a notebook on top of these
containers
we will talk a little bit more about our
data proc integration in
in the slides that follow claudia
platform also works with
data sources within a gcp like bigquery
so you'll be able to query data that's
stored within bigquery
and use that data to train your models
let's take a look at how ai platform
notebooks are architected
ai platform notebooks are designed to
work with a variety of compute instances
we just talked about how it works with
deep learning vms which are
gce container gce instances
with pre-installed deep learning
frameworks within the vm
ai platform notebooks also work with
data pro clusters
and data flow ai platform notebooks also
work with custom containers
which means that if you have a special
deep learning framework that you wanna
run you can create a custom container
out of it
and have ai platform notebooks work with
those containers
ai platform notebooks work with a
variety of data sources within gcp
for example you can query data from
bigquery
use that data as the basis to train your
model
ai platform notebooks are also well
integrated with git repositories and
other source control systems
so it's easy to push and pull code
into these repositories
so why would you want to use ai platform
notebooks
air platform notebooks makes it really
easy to get started with your model
development
since you don't have to deal with
installing these deep learning
frameworks
or setting up the notebook environment
you can get started very very quickly
in addition since ai platform notebooks
is a managed jupyter lab service
the environment around code development
is very familiar for data scientists
ai platform notebooks enabled you to
scale and control costs effectively
so you could start with a very small
instance for model development
and as you ramp up your training you
could move to a bigger vm or better yet
you could use a gpu or much powerful
machines
in order to train your models
ai platform notebooks comes with
security built in so as we talked about
uh vpcse iam controls
as well as cmac controls are built right
into ai platform notebooks
ai platform notebooks are also
integrated with other services within
gcp
so it plays within an ecosystem of
analytic tools as well as our
ai platform so ai platform makes it
really easy to build train and deploy
these models
let's talk about some recent updates
that we have made to our notebook
service in the last six months
we recently announced an integration
with kaggle
kaggle as you may know is a community of
five million data scientists
who write and share code with this
integration between kaggle
and ai platform notebooks customers have
access to
gcp's limitless and customizable compute
environment
that allows users to scale up their work
very easily
we've already seen thousands of
customers from kaggle go to cloud ai
notebooks
uh using this integration and we expect
these numbers to grow
in the next few months one of the recent
integrations we announced was with
dataproc
uh through the smart analytics framework
the smart analytics framework brings
together
apache beam and dataproc together with
ai platform notebooks
customers typically need to analyze
petabytes of data before starting to
work on a model
with this built-in integration with
spark analytics and deep learning can be
authored from one place
the data proc hub brings enterprise
controls to spark clusters
based on notebook interfaces if you want
to learn
further about apache beam notebooks
there's a fantastic tutorial
when you launch when you launch a
notebook using smart analytics framework
and when you choose apache beam
as you can see the experience to using
smart analytics framework is super easy
to get started
all you would have to do is pick the
smart analytics
frameworks choice and either pick apache
beam or data proc
distributions instead of a tensorflow or
a pi torch distribution as you would
for a deep learning environment so the
goal of cloudy eye notebooks is to help
you develop models quickly
and allow you to easily scale and
streamline that model
within your production workflows let's
take a
quick look at some of the examples
around how you can go about doing that
claudia notebooks provides a means to
plug
into your data pipelines that enables
feature engineering
as well as data labeling very easily
cloud ai notebooks helps you model your
data efficiently
with what-if analysis and also uh
embedded rml capabilities you can
evaluate your model quickly with feature
attributions
what-if analysis and continuous
evaluations
we've also built in algorithms like
optimization auto ml and nas
right into cloud ai notebooks that makes
model developments
uh simple and faster on top of this
uh claudia notebooks runs on a hybrid
platform and a multi-cloud platform that
also has access to some of the most
powerful compute you will find anywhere
in the world
for example tpus cloudera notebooks
makes it easy for you to scale and
streamline your model development with
ease
cloud ai notebooks works in an ecosystem
of
data services and ai services cloud ai
notebooks
is can be easily integrated into your
data pipeline so if you
ingest data using data fusion or
transform data using data proc
and put it into bigquery you can easily
access that data
label the data and use that data for
training as previously mentioned
notebooks also makes it easy to build uh
develop and train a model
with built-in tools such as pre-built
algorithms
auto ml and access to our training
service
claudia notebooks also makes it easy to
deploy these models
by verifying your model performance
using explainable ai
as well as directly deploying the model
into our prediction service
our prediction service also ships with a
continuous evaluation feature
that helps you to monitor the model once
it's in production
all these components are built with
access to a pipeline
that makes it easier to containerize and
monitor
the entire workflow end-to-end one such
tool that's built into
ai platform notebooks is explainable ai
explainable ai is a set of libraries
that help you figure out
why your model made a particular
prediction for example on the right
you can see a color-coded heat map of
what
the most important features were in
making a particular prediction
explainable ai can be used with tabular
image
text tensorflow models uh explainable ai
also ships with a built-in what if tool
when with a wardiff tool you could
change
the values for attributes that you're
building with a model
and figure out how much it impacts the
prediction of that particular model
explain explainable ai libraries are
already available in some of our deep
learning distributions today
and they'll be available in more in the
coming weeks
of course ai platform notebooks runs in
an ai optimized
infrastructure within gcp for example
our v3 uh tpu pods provide 84 percent
faster performance
in both object detection and machine
translation compared to on-prem
uh infrastructure this ai optimized
infrastructure is only
available on gcp among public clouds
and they clearly our outperform on-prem
systems in mlperf
looking ahead at our roadmap extending
beyond 2020
it's worth looking back on where we came
from
we launched ai platform notebooks in
beta in april 2019
and since the time that we have launched
we've seen tremendous interest amongst
enterprises
for developing models using cloud ai
notebooks
we've seen significant use of growth in
adoption in the last year
that helped us successfully ga the
product in march 2020.
beyond 2020 we hope to build in features
around machine learning operations
lineage tracking collaboration and
integration across our entire analytics
estate
as next steps we invite you to read our
notebooks manifesto blog that's
available on the google cloud blog site
as well as get started with cloud ai
notebooks
using a five minute tutorial that's
available on our product page
you can also learn about all the
features and in-depth documentation
on the product page on google cloud
platform
thank you for joining us today i hope
you enjoyed this presentation and you
have a good rest of the day and you
enjoy our other next 20 presentations